[Music]
the british government
can't get its people vaccinated fast
enough and that's true of meds
many of the western democracies but
china and russia have been sending
millions of dozens
of their coveted vaccines abroad it's
all about increasing their influence in
the post-pandemic world
it's a new great game which is the topic
of our cover story uh
for this week's magazine written by the
spectators broadcast editor host of our
chinese whispers podcast cindy you she
joins
me now cindy so
bottom line china and russia but
especially
china using the distribution of its
vaccine to developing countries
to further its influence on foreign
policy
yes it's it's an obvious thing to try to
do when you think about it because
uh even as early as last year china and
russia were sending out their ppe
donations to other countries when there
was a global shortage
uh china certainly was sending out its
own doctors which obviously at that
point
had known quite a lot about the virus by
march april kind of time
and now as vaccines so this phase is the
truly life-saving
phase and what a lot of countries around
the world are experiencing is that
actually they might have fizer orders or
they might have astrazeneca oxford
orders
but a lot of these deliveries are not
reliable and might not even start until
later this year
pushing them into the hands into the
arms of china and russia
who at least for china you know they're
not vaccinating their own people
at the breakneck pace i think we could
expect china to do
because they're just directing all of
their vaccines abroad so president xi's
vaccination target for late march is
only four percent of the population
that's
an incredibly slow pace from the country
because they see the soft power
potential here
so just to be clear in you could say
that
soft power for the let's take china soft
power for the chinese leadership which
comes from
exporting these vaccines in some ways
becoming is giving greater priority
than the regime vaccinating its own
people
yes i think so and but you know the
caveat to that is that china
has uh according to official figures
defeated covert within its borders so
obviously
there was that january outbreak where 22
million people at one point weighing
lockdown
but since then that outbreak has been
controlled daily figures show maybe less
than five new cases each day
and so most chinese people don't feel
like they need to be vaccinated anytime
soon because
they don't feel like they're going to
come across it when they go out go about
their daily business
so given there's a lack of pressure from
underneath uh the the
chinese communist party is finding it
easy to make that calculation
to export that abroad it seemed reading
your uh your cover story this week that
uh
it's almost like a new scramble for
africa in particular
the the chinese and the russians going
into zimbabwe was
one country you you mentioned uh going
into
african countries and offering the
pandemic
in areas where the chinese in particular
already have some influence i mean
there's been quite a lot of chinese
involvement in zimbabwe for example
exactly countries like zimbabwe have
amazing natural resources
rare earths that are so important to
develop high technology
uh components like mobile phones um
electric cars
all that sort of stuff that china
controls a lot of the world's supply of
you know china's belt and road
initiative that has been established in
the last five or so years
is essentially building these
infrastructure links along with the
diplomatic links in order for china to
grow
faster and bigger and of course some of
these recipient countries are
also getting a good deal out of it
especially the government's in control
of it
so as i say in my piece that a lot of
the strongmen leaders of the world
gravitate towards beijing's gifts you
know you've got president managua
of zimbabwe mugabe's successor saying
that his country feels greatly honored
by the chinese donation of vaccinations
you've got president erdogan
taking a picture of him getting jabbed
with sino farm one of china's two
vaccine producers
you've got duterte philippines very
controversial president
who you know has literally talked about
a violent and fatal war on drugs
squeezing hand sanitizer onto the
beijing emissary
in a very attentive way so all these
strong men um
love chinese investment and vaccinations
is the one way to prove
that china's friendship is worth a lot
and and i thought that was a fascinating
point that china was using the
distribution of the vaccine to kind of
help bolster
a strong men and their old men of uh
whom china
approves and that even went as far
as the leader of hungary who approved uh
sino farm one of the two major vaccines
that china produces
yeah and and viktor orban is not one of
these countries you know he doesn't lead
one of these countries that doesn't have
you know options he's part of the eu
scheme he doesn't think he's going to
get enough jabs that way
so that's why he's tend to sign no farm
he's also turned to sputnik russia's jab
but with sino farm he goes one step
further he says he's going to take the
sino-farm
vaccines at 79 efficacy over the fisa
one
at 95 efficacy because he says the
chinese have known as virus for the
longest i'm not sure that was quite on
brand for the beijing embassy
i noticed you said one i think it's
synovac
um they've been sending out even though
it's it's only very recently that it
actually got final approval but it
didn't stop them exporting it abroad
no and it didn't you know it didn't seem
to matter for the countries that
imported sinovac
either a lot of it was done under
emergency uh vaccination schemes with
china of course
has been using itself to vaccinate up to
a million people
domestically but yes you're right
sinopark hasn't
until this month it didn't get
regulatory approval within china
even now sino-vacanciano farm are not
being regulated for use
in the over 60s within china that hasn't
stopped them before being used in the
elderly in places like indonesia
so you know there's an interesting
question as to you know the different
regulatory
authorities and their different
standards and why the chinese themselves
don't think that their jobs
work for the elderly or safe enough for
the elderly just yet so you've got a
situation where erdogan's been
vaccinated
but maybe the 67 year old president xi
hasn't even been vaccinated yet
it's interesting too when you look to
the question of how does the west
respond because of course
the democratic pressure in the west is
on the governments to vaccinate their
own people first before they
start sending vaccines abroad but you
give one example of
involving the united kingdom using
manufacturing capabilities in
india to produce the oxford jabs
for export to poorer countries
in the region and this was one way of
which
the west was trying to combat some of
the
vaccine geopolitics of china and russia
tell us more about this indian venture
yes so this is very interesting china
for you know the last two decades may
have been a factory of the world
but india has is still the king when it
comes to vaccine manufacturing
the serum institute of india produces is
the largest vaccine manufacturer in the
world
in pre-covert times and they've signed a
deal with you know
a few different vaccine producers among
which is the oxford astrozenica jab
um they think that they can produce up
to a billion of this uh this year
and so while the uk's diplomatic focus
or why the uk's
nominal focus is on the british citizens
the oxford
astrazeneca jab has been given to the
sii in india
to be produced on mass and the modi
government that is distributing them
especially
in asia so you've got an interesting
situation where india and china are
fighting over their neighbors like sri
lanka and bangladesh
and for those two countries india has
won over and those two countries have
opted
for the oxford jab instead um you've
also got an awkward situation where it
seems like the oxford jab might not be
universally
applicable in the sense that in south
africa where the new strain has come
from
the oxford doesn't seem as effective so
india did
export some to that country but now it
doesn't seem to be really working there
sputnik has applied for approval in
south africa so you can see that china
and russia are never far behind
no indeed i just finally cindy uh
we've seen the british working in india
to do something which is not designed to
counter china or russia but it could
have that effect am i right you're
thinking we haven't heard anything from
the biden administration about this yet
yeah so the biden administration on the
first day of him coming in symbolically
uh kind of stopped their departure from
the wha in a sort of
you know we're not trump way um and they
also joined in
kovacs which is the who's developing
world vaccine scheme
uh they threw some money at it but it's
not nearly
enough uh america has also ordered like
many other high-income countries many
more vaccines than it will ever need
which you know adds to the pressure the
supply pressures around the world
and you know america i think it's biden
itself
himself he aims to vaccinate all
americans by july
so the focus is very much like the
british focus on on the home
home turf and which has led to you know
long-time
uh american allies like even mexico to
turn to sputnik
uh for help because they can't get their
hands on any pfizer so i think the
question is this before biden came into
power where there was all this talk
about how trump was
the obstacle to this international
alliance against china in particular
now that biden is in office you know
what is he actually doing that's
different to unite these western
countries
to see off this china chinese challenge
and it doesn't seem like there's much
going on there
at the moment
[Music]
you